hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show coming up
shortages of British vegetables could be
coming this year as Farmers struggle
with energy costs warns the head of the
national farming Union
emissions of Planet warming methane
remains stubbornly High the iea says
they could be slashed easily if oil and
gas giants used a fraction of their
bumper profits
new analysis shows higher gas prices
have cost the UK as much as the furlough
scheme in the years since Russia invaded
Ukraine
foreign
[Music]
Farmers Union in England and Wales is
warning there could be shortages of
vegetables this year as Farmers struggle
with the cost of energy now farming
Minister Mark Spencer and labor leader
Kia stammer have also been speaking at
the conference in Birmingham uh climate
reporter Victoria Seabrook is also there
she joins me live now Victoria tell us
what you've been hearing there
so the prevailing theme here today in
Birmingham really has been about food
security and what that means they're
saying is our ability to produce our
food domestically but this strong
warning from the nfu president Lynette
batters this morning I spoke to her
before the conference started and she
warned that because of high energy costs
which are set to go up again in April
for Farmers actually the cost of
production for some some vegetables
grown inside things like tomatoes and
cucumbers often grown inside they need
heat that's becoming too expensive that
means that some of these buildings are
already being mothballed and she said
that while the last thing any the last
thing any of us want is rationing there
is a risk of that this is what she told
me
I think they're going to be challenges
on availability of of some food items
you know tomatoes peppers being a case
in point salad ingredients in in general
um feel badge again that's going to be
challenging this year potatoes but I'm
hoping that we can resolve these issues
with the supply chain with government so
that we can give Farmers this level of
confidence and they will keep production
levels up
now of course this has come from the NS
you a very powerful Industry Group and
of course Lobby groups they do tend
sometimes to put out these very alarming
warnings as a way of getting government
to listen to what they want what they
want is help with their energy costs so
whether we will see rationing to the
extent that she's sort of hinted at
let's see but shortly after she spoke we
had we heard from Asda announced that
actually they were going to be limiting
the sale of some items that's for a
different reason that's because of
drought in southern Europe and North
Africa but it obviously it obviously
doesn't help and I put her concerns to
the farming Minister Mark Spencer who
was here as well and he refused to rule
out rationing he said he doesn't expect
to see it but he refused to rule it out
he also sort of sidestepped my question
about whether he would whether the
government would extend their energy
support a new scheme coming in in April
to Farmers most of them currently it
excluded from that and then finally
today we did hear from Kia starma as
well and he was uh he said multiple
times he talked about food security
being National Security so that really
is the the key theme here today and I
think that's a reflection of really
what's happened in the last year is that
we are now talking about security of all
these different areas when it comes to
farming energy food climate goals and so
on all in one go really understanding
how they link
Victoria Seabrook thanks very much
indeed
okay well let's take a look at some of
the day's other climate news for you now
and the outgoing head of the environment
agency has said everybody has to play
their part when it comes to improving
water quality and during his final
speech on water Sir James Bevin
highlighted improvements in beach and
bathing standards but acknowledged water
quality has flatlined urging farmers and
water companies to clean up their act
a peach restoration project in the
Cambridgeshire fens is trialing growing
Reeds that can be used to insulate homes
or peatland progress has been awarded
eight million pounds to restore 120
hectares of wetland that's an essential
natural tool for capturing and trapping
carbon The Five-Year trial will grow
bull rush read for insulation
and in Austria a dozen children are
taking their government to court to try
and force them to set tougher targets to
tackle climate change a lawyer
representing the children says the
current climate law from 2011 doesn't
sufficiently protect her clients from
harm
right now the International Energy
agency has accused fossil fuel
industries of doing too little to curb
methane emissions and undermining Global
Climate goals to limit warming now
despite economic uncertainty High Energy
prices and concerns over the security of
Supply the iea's global methane tracker
shows emissions remained stubbornly high
as they put it now earlier I spoke to
the iea's head of energy supply unit
Christoph mcglade I started by asking
him why we should be concerned about
methane tackling methane is among the
most important things that can be done
to limit near-term global warming
methane is a much more potent greenhouse
gas than carbon dioxide and in fact we
estimated around about 30 percent of the
global warming that's been experienced
today is caused by methane
and the analysis that we released today
suggested that unfortunately
methane emissions from the energy sector
Rose last year if we want to achieve our
climate targets we need to bring those
emissions down very very substantially
right so in order to do that what does
the industry really need to do and get
to grips with and presumably that would
be really costly and take a long time
this should not be a very costly thing
to do we saw last year for example
natural gas prices were incredibly high
and that should have given a real
economic incentive to reduce methane
emissions methane is basically the same
as natural gas and if natural gas prices
are high that means that that methane
has a real economic value
and so we estimate that around about
half of the methane emissions coming
from the energy sector today could be
reduced at no net cost
and in addition to that we saw last year
that a number of oil and gas companies
around the world made huge profits huge
windfall income as a result of the
global energy crisis
around about four trillion dollars they
made last year
and just three percent of that windfall
income would be enough to bring about a
huge reduction in methane emissions so
it should be possible to save money
while also helping to save the planet
well so it sounds like a real win-win
really doesn't it but as I understand it
um these pledges of by the fossil fuel
industry and to be clear we're talking
about methane leaks as a result of the
process and the infrastructure they've
made these pledges to uncover and fix
their leaking infrastructure from the
fossil fuel industry
um and yet they haven't done it what
what do you think needs to be done now
to make sure it is done
we have seen absolutely a huge number of
new policies coming through and
announcements by the oil and gas
industry but what we really need to see
is action on the ground spending some of
that huge amount of income that they
made last year investing that into
methane abatement
just to give one example here we know
that there are very large leaks that
occur they are now being detected by
satellites there's an ever increasing
amount of transparency
but normal oil and gas operations will
also release an awful lot of emissions
and we have existing Technologies to do
this a number of companies a number of
countries are producing oil and gas in a
way that doesn't result in a large
amount of methane so we need those
measures those practices carried out by
those best performing companies to be
adopted much more widely and also policy
makers need to step up they need to step
up their efforts they need to become
more ambitious in terms of the methane
reductions from occurring within their
own countries
now a person has spent 1 000 pounds for
every adult since the Russian invasion
of Ukraine a year ago that's according
to new analysis from the energy and
climate intelligence unit which shows
the cost of higher gas prices has been
equivalent to this 70 billion pounds
spent on the pandemic furlough scheme or
Britain has been one of the worst
impacts in Europe given our alliance on
gas for heating and generating
electricity on the grid well I'm joined
by Dr Simon cran mcgreen head of
analysis at the energy and climate
intelligence unit good to have you with
us here on the daily climate show
these figures are eye-watering and the
impact is so widespread
okay
absolutely that's correct so we want to
look back over this year of the gas
crisis since the invasion to understand
that the cost of buying gas and
wholesale markets and we estimate that
it's around 70 billion pounds and that
is around the price that the government
paid for the furlough scheme in the
pandemic and it's around 50 to 60
billion pounds more than we'd spend in a
normal year buying gas and of course
this wholesale gas is the core of the
problem but it's not the full extent of
the problem it's been driving increases
in gas bills even higher it's been
driving electricity prices up and it's
been driving wider inflation across the
economy such as in the food sector which
we heard about in your first item
right so would we say the answer then is
to turn to Alternatives and are we
talking about Alternatives or let's take
for example wind and solar where are we
at with that
so certainly uh if we want to reduce our
gas consumption for electricity then
Renewables are the obvious choice and
we're very fortunate that we do have
rather a large amount of Renewables
already in the UK we're well in our way
uh we generate each year about the same
amount from Renewables as we do from gas
so if it wasn't for the Renewables we
already have we would potentially have
been using twice as much gas for power
generation as we have in the past 12
months and that would have added an
extra 20 billion pounds to our costs
and we are making good progress towards
uh more renewable deployment and the
more we have the more we would save uh
on gas
okay we're going to leave it there Dr
Simon cran mcgreen thanks very much
indeed
thank you very much now just a reminder
that you can watch Tom Heap to send into
London's new super sewer this week
that's on Saturday and Sunday at 3 30
p.m right here on Sky News and before
you go we want your climate questions
anything that's ever mystified you about
the environment or whatever you want to
get to the bottom of just scan the QR
code on your screen right now and send
us your questions we'll try and have
them answered in the climate Show with
Tom Heap
and if you scan this QR code on your
screen right now you can listen to this
week's edition of the climate cast you
can listen And subscribe wherever you
get your podcast from
and thanks for watching that's all from
us today join us again on the daily
climate show same time tomorrow at 3 30
p.m bye-bye
[Music]